وفقا لمكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه فان الاشتباكات المسلحه
بالسودان تركزت حتى الان في العاصمه
الخرطوم والى الشمال منها في مروي تليها
في وسط البلاد مدينه الابيض بولايه شمال
كردفان وبالاتجاه غربا نجد مدينه الفاشر
عاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور وكذلك مدينه
الضعاين عاصمه ولايه شرق دارفور تليها
مدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور
وتعتبر ملتقا للطرق الرابطه بين الشرق
السودان وغربي وبالاتجاه غربا تظهر
زالونجي في ولايه وسط دارفور وكذلك جنينه
في ولايه غرب دارفور اما شرقا فهناك
القضارف وكذلك الدمازين في النيل الازرق
اما بالنسبه لحركتي اللجوء والنزوح فان
الفارين من الخرطوم يذهبون في اكثر من
اتجاه شمالا باتجاه بورسودان والحدود مع
مصر وصولا الى الحدود مع ليبيا وشرقا
باتجاه كسلا على حدود اريتريا والقضارف
على حدود اثيوبيا وكذلك عبر النيل الابيض
باتجاه دوله جنوب السودان التي تستقبل
اللاجئين من ولايه شرق دارفور اما
اللاجئون من ولايه جنوب دارفور فيتوجهون
نحو جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ومي ولايات
غرب دارفور يتجه اللاجئون نحو الحدود مع
تشاد